hello
today's it , how does this work wait can
I go on YouTube live oh let's see go go
on our Twitter oh god take that painting
down though that's true but let's we
still gotta like do nothing for 15
minutes
I'm will commercial break
14 people maybe linked it to discord all
the channels yeah
YouTube live will have a discredit it's
a channel anything why is Andy dressed
up why not be dressed up you guys tell
us how good this quality is cuz from me
it looks fantastic
I got a little more so we know details
have not been and that's why you well
you're gonna know they're cause increase
for hard let's get the like a couple of
people have oh we have a hundred a lot
of people few minutes but we're gonna
dice all right guys I'm gonna roll this
dice and we got a seventeen the good
news is we're not increasing the price
we you know what's the good news is
today the 17th why
well nothing then we could have played a
little you know it's the 17th we rolled
a 17 not sponsored yet but
okay let's get started um let's get
started with the 129 people watching Oh
someone was trying to sleep they got
added all right sure yeah
so you off comma Connect just called
comp let's go call the connect to the
app store yeah
comma connect you know they make the
font size smaller you know we might drop
the connect at some point but in here
this is gonna work so I can like click
on my Honda Civic here it's not black
and white in real life by the way
oh yeah took color oh my gosh I keep my
phone in black and white so it's less
addictive
don't be so Silicon Valley George but um
yeah you can like see where your car
drove it's gonna load up the video here
this was just me driving around the
block last week in my civic one of the
heels take a long time to learn this one
works calm connect is using yeah we
could do more announcements all later um
so guys if you want to go right now
- I'm gonna tweet it out right now we
have any public API at API kamidana AI
and you guys can go there and you guys
can check it out so is that the box yeah
[Music]
yeah and that's use today everything on
there is available in production and
used by comma Connect Explorer Cabana
and hopefully the tools that y'all are
gonna write with this you know this has
been a you know we're highly requested
desired features for quite a while
released so yeah I'll post that tweet
and Twitter of the treatment in discord
yeah
so all of the data that you upload to us
is uploaded through this API and then
redownload through this API we make
things available to you well you can
like just interact with your devices you
can download all the raw files you can
see things about routes you can see did
your device location through a theme huh
yeah Athena Athena is the service that
runs on your on and then this API if you
go down to Athena lets you actually
interact with your device live on the
network so our server exit proxy server
it's the server goes back down to the
once that's over
yeah that's very nice - exactly
click zoom in on this monitor so they
can move the tripod I'm gonna move the
tripod oh they couldn't even like see
what I was doing on the computer I would
like to get a tripod with wheels you
know yeah yeah the next you guys know
all your eons have dongle IDs and a
segment is one minute of driving and
then a route is a bunch of seconds we
use JWT use to authenticate you go over
here to JWT comma dot a UI you can grab
yourself a JWT I'm not gonna do that in
front of you someone someone will type
it all in somebody would go to all the
trouble you're going to type in the date
may be truncated actually the mm-hmm you
can get diverse so many digits
characters yeah yeah but yeah the way so
you can just go right in here to the
compensator ET fleur-de-lis I can click
login yeah you login with your Google
account
yeah you can paste it in on the API
Doc's here and then all of the example
requests on the right column you can
paste right into your terminal and try
it out with your data nice you can get
stuff about user stuff about your device
all your routes your data life will not
live video streams video streams I've
sworn cabana use that derive data we're
talking about stuff about vehicles how
open pilot talks ena which is the
service to talk to all the pilot all
your annotations that use an explorer
and then one global leader boy yeah it's
actually just the top 40 go but like you
used to see in the community page so
yeah
highly encouraged cost them leaderboard
customer leaderboard app how we doing
we're 153
where have you been man Oh does that
mean you can build your own Explorer
well you could do one better than that
one better than that and use our
Explorer five yeah - the thing but we're
gonna make the Explorer Explorer is
open-source
oh yeah I'm gonna hide the you're right
you're right I'm just gonna look at you
and II oh yeah we comments or absolutely
still a thing you'll see them in the API
Docs yeah comments really appreciate all
the annotations that have been provided
whenever you disengage or nauseous
steering wheel bit and you go on
Explorer and commit an annotation
especially all the comments we've
received associated with the annotations
are incredibly useful so we go back and
improve the driving system based on your
feedback yeah but now explores open
source really you know once you see
issues created wanna see issues resolved
pull requests are accepted you know calm
has really been accepting a lot of pull
requests lately and comments team and
you know our open source ecosystem is as
healthy and active as ever so you know
we're trying to get everything out there
so that so that we can build calm a on
all right
no but then other people said it was
fine but you know what we're gonna get a
proper mic audio you can get that from
your I can hold a boom we're gonna get a
boom that you just like plug in one more
thing so Explorer is the tool who are
annotating the drives and reviewing the
drives Cabana is the tool for exploring
the can data on your car we have this
great project called open BBC which has
been in the works for two years
yeah they came up with it early spring
2017 so all the cars have they don't
have public eight guys the car is the
way our modules communicate with each
other is all secret the manufacturers
have this documentation file called the
DBC but you know you can try asking them
for it I don't think that's gonna go
over that well or you can reverse
engineer it and in open DBC here we have
really all mainstream cars now reverse
engineer by people and they're pretty
complete and it allows you to get things
like your your wheel speeds you can get
your steering angle sensor right here we
used to have this thing called Cabana
issues where you could publish your
issues about Cabana Cabana head bugs
we're doing we're doing one better than
that now we're not just gonna you know
look at look we've been hired a full
time person to fix all the Cabana issues
that cost money and we're company we're
trying to make money so we're gonna do
one bed we're gonna open source it so
you guys can fix the issues yourself
right here at the comic
Wow is it it's really that easy huh also
explore and oh we should put licenses on
them
that's a good so both of these
applications are based on react and we
are using the latest , API and DM
package which is also under comma API on
our github which implements the API spec
that we showed you earlier so I hope
that that everyone plays around with
these and customizes them in the ways
they want and the ways that we all deem
fit to merge back in emergent good yeah
someone's asking how does anyone start
contributing to the codebase is there
any tutorial on walkthrough of the
codebase the instructions to get started
on the project or in readme at the root
of each repo and you know since they're
written in JavaScript and react very
cross-platform you know pretty pretty
easy to get familiar with it should be
easy to get up and running and make
simple changes and see them reflected in
front of you that's the beauty of the
web you can just make a change and the
tools are so good that it'll
automatically reload in front of you and
show you it did so yeah read
names Docs yeah so was asking to post
that link and we can
perfect thanks for making this guy yeah
yeah cabanas 2017 brainchild we were all
sitting downstairs in the basement of
the old come office and we were like how
are we gonna pour all these cars we came
up with open D BC and we came up with
Cabana just some one one random evening
so you know ideas blossom and open DBC
is a incredibly successful project and
we wouldn't have been able to do it
without all of you it's not done yet
every time new car comes out and all the
cars that haven't been out of the map
yet we still need your help so hop on
Cabana get a neon and help reverse an
engineer every car that we can cuz a
Kyle boat was on Lake Street and you
guys can watch the watched the podcast
and you know cruise is virtually making
an aftermarket self-driving kit but they
gave up not because it wasn't a market
but because it's technically with a card
how are you going to support Carl I
believe said 20 to 50 cars
[Music]
well well I'm only up to Honda thirteen
fourteen fifteen sixteen seventeen
eighteen nineteen twenty twenty-one
twenty-two twenty-three twenty-four
twenty-five twenty-six thirty-six
thirty-seven 38 39 40 41 42 43 44 45 46
47 48 and if you include the model years
we probably got like 65 right there so
and that's dude tools like Cabana I'm
making it possible to crowdsource this
kind of work
we don't own 45 different cars this is
similar idea right how are we going to
get rid of the long tail of issues so
always remember open pilot and every
other driving system today is level two
which means it works in conjunction with
the human not alone pay attention at all
times in correct its mistakes now its
mistakes you're usually you can do these
things explore was this to kind of show
you what the car was thinking at the
time we draw the models we draw where
the car was going we've already open
sourced amount of tools that we used and
explore so the libraries we use to draw
the HUD and read the open power logs are
the open source under common AI
organization vm so we have comm a I log
reader to read logs in in JavaScript
coming we have our old JavaScript
engineer shadow ops Chris bakery Road
Cathy and P JavaScript tooling so you
can read all your log so you can check
it out yeah you just think about how bad
all the other throughout the people
modding cars
well you the tools are terrible like we
tried a ball I don't want build any I
never want to build anything all right
if I can download something I drove down
you think I wanted to build pandas
yeah we built Cabana cos you know you
got vector tools which are proprietary
for Windows and cost thousands of
dollars and we thought there's no reason
that good free tools shouldn't exist now
now cabanas pretty truly free MIT
license and open source and cross you
know compatible across the platform
doesn't require two hundred mega windows
download you got to know oh I need lease
I need visual C components
redistributable 2015 oh now you just
need Chrome yeah yeah Stream this chalk
copy it's choppy wait you don't think we
should be on Wi-Fi well I know because
I'm on why fine fine cool yeah check out
everything we've released today submit
issues give feedback on discord and
Twitter and everything and never excited
to see what you build and any questions
yeah yeah we'll take reasonable
questions no product announcement guys
it's for developers remember
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's where you tube autoplay is the
bring back the old office I love comma
but work out how to appeal to the normal
drivers that's what's what's happening
in the announcements that aren't for
developers as announced this
announcements for develop first through
the masses yeah definitely for the
masses attract to the masses row we have
a new slogan oh oh yeah check out her
Twitter check out our Twitter you know
how it used to be go sure I get rid of
the hashtag anti hype I think we should
just like make driving chills simple
enough you don't need to make driving
chill period right that's our that's our
new slogan makes ride and chill it's
like ghost riding for the masses but
it's make driving
how many retweets what about the dataset
though no soon actually what about the
Dennison you know what what about the
day is that why don't you go and comment
search for comments UK 19 what about the
dataset okay I'm just gonna link you
back here on Twitter what about the data
already publish bro we hope that stories
data at the end of last year how do you
plan on growing your data set it's
already too big guys it's too much
alright maybe we should take them to
Center yeah we have 119 over a 200 all
to do that but maybe lifers yeah I know
oh let's talk about the eons without the
extra costume scoffs bro I'm not making
any money off of your costumes
why should I pay for it cuz you made
poor choices I said we live in a
democracy
I assume you made poor choices when you
voted without Netflix on e on No
yeah we have a lot of data guys data is
really expensive to store you know so
who's our largest yeah yes which is
going down we're bringing all the data
right here to San Diego mm-hmm yeah it's
like retirement data stream start kar
komak connect it seems to be a gimmicky
feature that people want and the only
business car bug is early in there
oh wow this treatment is lagging it's
terrible you still have a country
0.6 when we don't make comments on
future products eg I navigate an opening
I'll say this anyone who wants navigate
on copilot should read the Consumer
Reports review of navigator on autopilot
now Consumer Reports for a nuance
company no not there not there not
bought out and all sold out at least as
far as I can tell and they're very Pro
autopilot but navigating autopilot is
not good when it makes lane change it
doesn't worse than human right usually
we only try to do things where no
driving miserable Lane it's pretty easy
to do better than a human people's
aren't that good even if you're not like
super distracting sometime like the
wheel drift a little and jerk it back
right control loops are much faster and
when you're making a lane change there's
so much human intuition that goes into
it that unless you can actually do it in
a better than the other way you
shouldn't be doing it at all
and that seems to be like most of what
navigate on autopilot is now combined
with navigation in like intelligent ways
this is something we're interested in
the future of a building something that
looks like navigating an autopilot and
works like navigating on I got an
original model three boats great various
a little Bob I try to navigate on I
wouldn't shut that I think it's I think
it's a alpha yeah here load Anika's
people definitely don't like it someone
say in statistics show that auto steer
is obvious to you look people really use
this is a great article person car is
that great journalist oh the one that
breaks 200 this one oh I think we're
talking about the one that breaks down
like which features people want you know
yeah what's the latest development on
the Corolla it drives
okay maybe I should carry tweets about
three tweets people buy things by the
way please buy things shop up da da da
di we love when you buy things
that's exactly right it makes it very
easy to buy what we should call it the
roller not the Corolla yes someone just
caught that that's brilliant
like the ad chord patron why buying you
a trip to Europe bro because someone in
community bought chase and yeah camera
will man thank you I am a woman I know
that's true someone wants to know the
best car for 0.6 parole Corolla check
out longer Clio - yeah give a shout out
to the guy who helped you yeah I think
it's Steven along but do you just hear
any new announcements so what we
announced today is that we now have an
API I will post a public API
it is right there we've also open
sourced Explorer and Cabana the tools
that you can use the last three days
let's have a call to action wrap-up
those are good to have oh yeah yeah you
can go and comment on Cabana issues and
we're gonna turn this off and you could
pork the issues over to Khamenei on
cabana we already have issue
oh these might be internal vegetables oh
yeah remove the stupid three minutes go
by um yeah all right yeah
cool